[Music]
sandy is in ogden
utah hi sandy welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hello everyone hi hi
so my question is is how much do you say
optimal um emergency fund is
to have in your bank because you say
king of cash
if that's true three what happens when
go ahead what happens when when
financially the banks are going to be in
trouble and
they end up closing granted they say
they're fdc
um fbic insured
but supposedly that fund isn't fully
funded either so what do people
do should do i'm sorry
i i'm not aware that banks are closing
in mass
did i miss no not yet no not yet
what's your prediction why is why are
you predicting the end of the world what
do you think why do you think they're
all going to close
well because the way the economy is
going it's booming
explaining booming
okay it's recovered uh the unemployment
rate is
back down after covet it's not all the
way down
but it's uh you know we had 40 million
people unemployed
after the pandemic but it's gone back
you're in
utah is ogden utah economy not working
i would have thought it was doing well
it's doing all right i mean it's
not stellar but it's going to be a slow
process for a lot of people to come back
and a lot of people are hurting
okay well here's oh but i'm retired
and my husband's still working and we
have 401s and we have investments which
we don't plan
touching okay but we have a house
payment left which
i just refinanced from okay well let me
let me kind of walk you through this all
right
if enough of the banks
went belly up that they drained the fdic
fund and even beyond that the government
chose not to prop up
the remaining banks after the fdic fund
was there because the government was in
trouble
long before that all happened your 401k
would have been worth almost nothing
because if all of the banking system in
america has collapsed
most of the companies you've invested in
in the 401k
would have collapsed and so we're
talking about an apocalyptic
situation before you'd lose your
emergency fund in the bank it's insured
for
up to 250 000 so i feel real safe
in an fdic or um bank
or if you're with a credit union insured
by the ncua
uh same situation but for credit unions
i feel very safe i've got
my personal money in a bank and so i
feel
very very comfortable with that
the only time in the last hundred plus
years that we've even come close to
being scared about that was back in 2008
and it was uh there was a moment or two
that we were actually looking at
the fdic and the and how
weak it really is in comparison to all
the banks that it covers
but much like a lot you know uh like a
lot of things where insurance is
involved they don't keep enough
to cover every single person for
instance a life insurance company does
not keep enough cash
to where if everyone they had covered
died that year that they that they
couldn't do it right they could only
cover about 10 20
of or whatever the percentage is that
that
um usually would die or an increase a
pad above that
and the same thing's true with the fdic
there's not enough money in the account
to
make good all of the banks
but even then uh the government steps in
there was a thing
so i i would feel safe and i would put
three to six months of expenses
in your emergency fund uh to answer your
question
sandy but um the
um there was a thing in the um
80s uh the we used to have these things
when
i first started in business called
savings and loans
and the fdic version that insured them
was called the fslic and
um the savings and loan industry
there was a huge fraud a guy went to
jail in arizona and
milken and um uh
then reagan changed the tax law and a
lot of the s
l's had money tied up in uh
tax based uh in real estate investments
and so like these apartments all of a
sudden became worth half what they were
worth because it changed tax law
and they tossed the keys to the fl to
the snl's and they ended up being in the
real estate business
instead of the lending business and it
broke them it
closed the closed them down well the
fslic did not have enough to cover
the deposits uh then it was so it was
transferred to the government became the
resolution trust corporation the rtc
the government took it over and made all
the deposits good took all the assets
and
and you know sold them off covered
because i bought some of the real estate
from the government that they'd taken
back from the
failed snls and so there's a process
that went through there but no one
that had money in an snl lost big money
or
virtually no one lost big money on that
so in those kinds of cases there's
usually something like that that occurs
and you're okay so i feel pretty safe
for you sandy
because my money's there too this is the
dave ramsey show